le monde de l'intérim souffre parfois
d'une image de précarité et pourtant une
structure propose de nombreux services
pour faciliter le quotidien des
intérimaires le fonds d'action sociale
du travail temporaire qui organise
régulièrement des réunions d'information
à la cité des métiers de trappes
mutuelle aides à la mobilité ou encore
garde d'enfants les services sont
multiples exemple avec le logement au
niveau du logement si quelqu'un donc un
intérimaire doit déménager et que le
propriétaire donc est réticent on m'a
des 600 heures de missions en fait on
peut se porter garant pendant toute la
durée du bail donc pour l'intérimaire on
peut également avancer sa caution dès la
première heure d'émission j'ai toujours
travaillé à l'intérim tous les avantages
que
intérimaire pour bénéficier de
de l'intérim je connaissais pas avant
je lui découvrir les avantages proposés
par le fasse tout simplement parce que
dans mon parcours professionnel il est
possible que je fasse de l'intérim et
donc j'ai anticipé il ya certainement
certaines propositions week qui
m'intéressent rond comme la mutuelle par
exemple prochaine réunion d'information
du faste le 19 octobre à 14 heures à la
cité des métiers de trappes en 2011 le
faste à délivrer 85000 prestation est
mobilisé 20 millions d'euros